after days of depressing racial violence
across israel
friday night in jaffa brought a new low
mobs throwing fire bombs into homes
including that of 12 year old muhammad
he and his younger sister
burned his father said they'd been
sitting in the living room when the
molotov cocktail was thrown in
he rushed muhammad to the bath neighbors
came to help
but across israel neighbours are turning
on each other on a scale that few can
remember
more gun violence in lod where two
jewish men were shot the previous night
by palestinians
one of our guys tried to leave from
behind the mosque but he was shot we
don't know if it was the settlers or
police or undercover forces
the town has seen religious sites
desecrated a jewish synagogue
a muslim cemetery the prime minister was
there again on friday
groups of writers are coming from the
arab public and harming jews because
they are jews
i am explicitly saying that this is not
the entire arab public
and not even the majority of the arab
public but it is a significant minority
that harms violently and also harms the
fabric of life we have built over the
years between jews and arabs
and so to the crackdown israel's
internal security agency
detaining a senior cleric of the
northern islamic movement for alleged
incitement
accompanying violent confrontations saw
dozens more palestinians injured
some critically netanyahu himself stands
accused of fueling this fire
courting and legitimizing the extreme
racist right
at the last election failing fully to
tackle gun crime
within palestinian-israeli areas for
years before
in the occupied west bank a violent
flare-up of a different kind
palestinians confronting soldiers
enforcing a military occupation
this was just west of ramallah this was
hebron
and this close to the illegal israeli
settlement of beitel
we're trying to defend our land we have
no arms nothing
as in gaza and israel the toll mounted
quickly
israeli forces using live ammunition
shooting protesters dead
hundreds were injured
in occupied east jerusalem jewish
settlers and palestinians
faced off one palestinian man was shot
and injured
as well as erupting in the occupied west
bank and continuing here
in occupied east jerusalem this violence
between jews and arabs
is continuing to flare in israel itself
the image that shot so many earlier this
week was the beating of said musa
he's now given an interview to israel's
channel 13 tv
saying his assailants first asked him if
he was an arab
yes how can i help was his reply
the simple open innocence of that
question now seems from another time
harry fawcett al-jazeera occupied east
jerusalem